critics say the world wouldn't be ready
for this new superman
well [ __ ] them
man of steel i don't know why i'm doing
the black power sign but
it seems fitting for the occasion if you
don't want to hear my whole review and
you just want to know how i felt well
here's how i felt
i [ __ ] love this movie
here's what i want to start off with
it's a fresh take on superman
it's dark it's realistic when i first
heard that's what they were going for i
was like how the [ __ ]
are they gonna possibly pull that off
because i think we're so used to
superman being like this
super lighthearted cartoonish type of
character but in this movie they managed
to pull it off so well
largely in part due to henry cavill's
performance this dude
look at him look at him yes that's right
he's joining the club
i'm gonna suck his dick one day this
dude's awesome people are complaining
that the fact that they cast a british
guy to play an american
you know what kyle is not um american
he's an alien and that's one thing i
really liked about this movie cal
l is a science fiction character this
movie is has
so much sci-fi elements to it just the
first 10 minutes when they're exploring
krypton
holy crap never seen krypton look so
[ __ ] cool before and they have
jarrell on krypton and they make jarrell
you know superman's dad even cooler than
ever he's not just a badass scientist
he's also a badass who can kick
bad asses anyway back to cavill this
dude does a really good job people are
not used to seeing a superman like this
so i can see why some people are a
little bit contemplated on it
but this guy he's much more the silent
type he's much
darker than before he's got a little bit
more of an anger inside of him much more
sense of loneliness and vulnerability
which i think makes more sense when
you're going for a realistic
interpretation of superman to be the
charming christopher reeves version that
works well for the richard donner
version but guess what haters
this is not the richard donner version
it's a completely fresh
reboot on superman which i love so
much never seen a superman like this
before another thing too i really like
the fresh take on lois lane
and superman warning minor minor spoiler
but it happens fairly early on in the
movie she ends up discovering who
superman is but it makes her much more
interesting dynamic we've already seen a
billion times
of lois lane as this stupid reporter who
cannot tell
that clark kent is superman and playing
a damsel in distress kind of role but no
you get a much more
hardcore investigative type of reporter
someone who's really in the field a lot
more someone who actually goes out of
the way that is smart enough to
figure out who superman is yes there is
a lack of romance between them there is
not a big romantic chemistry but to say
that the relationship does not make
sense
is very much incorrect i actually quite
enjoyed their relationship and i thought
kaville and
amy adams played off each other very
well and plus look at amy adams
look at her if she had a dick i would
suck it too
i'm not gay but you know but she was a
female yeah yeah absolutely the number
one thing people are talking about with
this film seems to be the action this
film has a
shitload of action the action god was
taking a [ __ ] and just
out came a bunch of different types of
action scenes
and all of them are [ __ ] awesome yes
there is that moment that
most people are having including myself
where you're like he could have dialed
down the action just a little bit
but it's like at the end of the day it's
all very badass especially that finale
with general zod and superman oh and
general zod played by michael shannon if
you haven't heard of michael shannon
supposedly
he is the greatest actor who has ever
lived on this [ __ ] planet
he is so good in this role what i like
that he did with it was he made him so
human he didn't play like mr evil guy
you actually understand this dude you
get where he's coming from and michael
shannon's not trying to outshine anyone
he does a very very good job in this
role i will find him
and suck his dick now to talk about the
directing of zack snyder
almost one of the most hated directors
currently we have today this dude
wow blew my mind he managed to make such
a realistic interpretation of superman
yes it's still a science fiction movie
but it's actually a very believable
world
i love that it's such a serious tone i
love everything he does with it with the
craft zooms and the handheld camera
oh great he really knows how to work
with the cinematographer very well and
yes
yes there is not a lot of slow motion
thank
the lord jesus for that what was
interesting is that most of this movie
is actually very
handheld a lot of time the handheld
choice i don't always agree with because
i
it seems like such a pretentious move to
me a lot of times it's so obvious what
they're going for to try to make it feel
more
real but in this movie it worked
surprisingly well just forget everything
you know about superman
and accept that this is a completely
fresh take just learn to readjust a
little bit the music in this
absolutely brilliant beautiful you are
going to want to
soar once you hear this music huh zimmer
i
love you honestly i can talk about this
movie forever there's so much uniqueness
behind it i've seen us so many different
versions of superman this one to me
is absolutely my most favorite one it's
perfect for the modern day and on top of
that too
it's a great companion piece to batman
begins let me get straight to the point
here
all in all i gotta say matt of steel got
it super right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my show why don't you go ahead scroll
that comment box below
and tell me which one has been your
favorite superman story told it could be
anywhere from
the 90s show to smallville to the
richard donner version
to this current day version which one is
your favorite superman now that man of
steel is out and if you want to see a
more in-depth review of man of steel go
ahead and check out my show called
reasons to see that i do with my buddy
jerry where we're gonna give you a
breakdown
of reasons to see and maybe not to see
man of steel and last but not least if
you want to get updated every time one
of my reviews is out
go ahead and subscribe to my channel by
clicking on the link right
here by my penis which yes
i call man of steel
comment below and tell me would you suck
henrika bill's date